Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
you are in for a treat.
Ooh, I'm excited about this.
I've been looking forward to this one.
We want to introduce you
to our other best friend in college.
Who we've kept in touch with.
I mean, we'll get into some of that,
but we wanna introduce you
to the one, the only Gregg Hartsfield.
Gregg you're here. Well, no, you're not.
Hey, I made it.
You made it but you're--
You made it to your home and a phone
that you're communicating through.
And you're in Washington State.
Yes, I'm there, that's where is here.
You're still in Burbank.
No, we've talked about Gregg
a lot throughout the years.
I mean, most recently, if
you watch our other show,
"Good Mythical Morning,"
you know that the black bass
that was on the set for
basically many years.
Basically.
Most of the history of the show,
was a bass that Gregg gave us
when he left to go to
Argentina right after college.
So we are talking of like 20 years ago.
So we had the bass.
The bass was played in a few
early Rhett and Link songs
when I would like lay down a baseline.
We later realized that I
could just play the guitar,
and then we would just it
lower an octave in garage band.
Yeah. Yeah.
But recently, Gregg
asked for the bass back,
and so that whole story is unfolding
on "Good Mythical Morning," but--
So, by the way, if you have something
that you think can fit in that space
that the base was,
occupied, you let us know.
There's a Twitter post.
[Link] You post your photo and,
basically, your sales pitch
as to why this thing is special.
Hopefully, it's the base.
I'm trying to lobby for
the bases for Alabama.
Yeah.
To donate one of his bases.
I just think that would be funny.
And if he won't, I'm just
hoping for a guy named Gregg,
preferably a guy named Gregg
with two G's at the end.
So, Gregg, have you
received the base back?
It's here. It's here.
It needs to be restrung.
You have not maintained the base.
It wasn't broken when it arrived.
It just needs to be refreshed.
Yes. It needs a light
buffing and some new strings.
Yeah. I mean, base strings
do not last two decades.
They probably last like,
You might get, I don't know,
six months outta some base strings?
Now listen, if you don't
replace these strings
and play this thing within
like the next two weeks,
you're at risk of us
asking you years from now
if you played it, and
you'll be embarrassed.
You'll have to start lying
to us that you're playing it.
So you need to get on it, man.
I'm working on the plan.
I didn't have a plan till just now,
so now I have a plan.
I don't really know the
details of the plan,
but there's a plan.
There's a plan.
How good did you get it bass
before you gave us that bass?
I was not so good.
From one to 10, I might be a 2.
Okay. Right.
It's fine.
You've been holding steady at a two.
I did go to a jazz club in Raleigh
in Open Mic Night, one time,
and for some reason, people
thought I played bass well,
but I don't think I did.
Are you talking about
when you were in college?
No, that was I after college.
I went with Tom from our church.
Okay. And you did a little bass thing.
Man, I didn't know you were moonlighting.
I do remember that you
had an acoustic guitar
when we first met.
I think you could play some
Grateful Dead songs, but...
All right. So tell us,
what do you remember about
meeting us for the first time?
So I've spent the last 30 minutes
trying to recreate this memory in my mind.
Nothing really pops out,
When I first met you guys,
I think it was a freshman year of college,
and I saw, read up on the stage a crew,
and I was like,
"There's that guy up there."
That didn't really care.
Didn't really even want
to be at the meeting.
We really didn't meet, in my recollection,
until sophomore year,
so, well, if that was the
first time you saw me,
that was your sophomore year?
Because I may have gotten
up front freshman year
for something, but I
wasn't emceeing until,
because I lobbied to
emcee in my freshman year,
knowing that the guy who
was a senior was graduating.
Oh, okay.
So I talked to Mark and was like,
"Can I emcee next year?"
Because I remember it being the
beginning of sophomore year.
That was definitely
when we became friends.
Pretty early on sophomore year.
But what was your impression of us?
I mean, I remember my impression of you,
but I'll let you go first.
Whatever you remember
of when we first started
becoming friends, sophomore year.
It was within the context
of the campus crusade.
Todd Smith, who was, and still
is a full-time staff member,
he was leading Bible
studies and organizing
the weekly meeting and a lot
of the organizational stuff
that happened on campus
with the organization.
But he knew you, and then he knew us,
and then we must have
met through Todd. Right?
I think so. I think so.
But I don't recall.
I know that like we hit it off.
We hung out all the time.
Yeah, we were fast friends.
I really enjoyed hanging
out with you guys.
So the thing that I remember is,
I mean, I don't remember
the specific thing,
but I have to know that
our first impression
of Gregg was, "This dude is different."
I mean, and take this in a positive way,
but like, this dude is strange and funny
and he's just different
than anybody else we knew,
so we were very much drawn to,
everybody in campus crusade, I don't know,
it's just like everybody
fit into a certain mold.
Well, I mean--
But Gregg, you stood out.
You were like this super skinny dude
with these real floppy clothes, like us.
You were dressed how we-
These huge jeans.
That's the thing.
So we were at NC State, which is already,
it's a technical school, right?
It's a technical state
school in the south,
and we were also then sort of filtered
into this Christian group.
So there was a little more,
for lack of a better
word, Southern preppiness.
So--
Right.
So there's a certain, I don't know,
if you grew up in the south,
you know exactly what I'm talking about,
but a guy who will wear a
polo shirt and a trucker hat.
It was a little frat-ish-
It's a little fratty.
But not full on frat.
So you're not quite redneck
and not quite preppy,
and that was most of the people.
Now we kinda came in thinking
that we were rock stars,
we're dyeing our hair, bleaching our hair,
wearing these big baggy pants.
Embracing the alternative '90s scene.
So we were really leaning hard into that,
and it wasn't difficult to stand out
because there wasn't a lot
of people in our small circle
doing that,
and then Gregg comes along,
and it was immediately like,
"Oh, this guy, he feels like
"he's on a very similar wavelength."
I mean, and we thought
that you were a stoner.
In like a really, you had this delivery,
I remember whenever we would see
Gregg would be like, "What's up?"
I was kind of stoner.
Okay. Yeah.
So there was some recovering
stoner thing happening.
So by the time we met you, you were like,
yeah, you were being introduced
to the straight narrow
through campus crusade,
and we were, Todd was trying to bring you
into the fold basically, right?
Yeah.
He was putting in me in
my, in the right place.
Yeah. And when he
introduced us, I was like,
we just found you very
funny, very entertaining.
Whenever we would say, "What's up?"
You remember what Gregg would say?
"Good."
It's just like anybody who, that's what,
nobody's response to,
"What's up?" Is, "Good."
And every time. And you were always good.
You were always good.
How else do you respond to that question?
Well, you want me to
break it down logically?
Because when you say, "What's up?"
What you're asking is what is up?
Like what's going on?
You're asking me, "How are you doing?"
Well, I mean, you gotta cut to the chase.
If you say, "What's up?"
You could respond with, "Well, I'm good."
That's one of the things that's up,
but you were just like, "Good."
"Nothing much, man." I'm headed to class.
I'm going back to my dorm.
You want come over and
play some Twisted Metal?
Or actually, really,
proper response at that age
with a familiar person to,
"What's up?" Is, "What's up?"
Yeah.
Just say it back, but--
No one, before, during, or since,
said, "Good," and that's why we knew
that you had to be a
constant part of our lives.
I think that we were in this place,
we had gone through our
freshman year together.
We had made a lot of friends.
We hadn't really, really found our group.
It was just the two of us on the weekends.
I was going back home
to see my girlfriend.
We were still involved in
our band, The Wax Paper Dogs.
So freshman year was like
this transition period,
but sophomore year, we
had basically decided
we were deciding to quit the band.
You were deciding and
lobbying to be the MC
of campus crusade's weekly meeting.
Yeah.
I was a already involved in the music team
of the weekly meeting.
So I was upfront singing,
leading the music.
So I was like, we were
moving in these positions
where we were visible positions early on,
and so college for us, at the
beginning of sophomore year
was, okay, I've broken
up with my girlfriend,
now, it's like all in on college
and right about that same
time, very early on, we meet,
and it was just like, it was
always fun to have you around.
So it was just like,
In a lot of ways, we became
this trio very quickly.
Do you remember any more
of what you thought of us?
I'm not fishing for a compliment,
but I told you that I thought
you were basically gloriously weird,
and it was like, unlike anybody else.
So I was like, let's do this.
I just thought you guys were my friends.
I just wanted to, In my life,
I haven't had a ton of friends
up to that point.
And I meet you two, and I
was like, this is my people.
This is who I wanna hang out with.
I mean, you seemed like
you were in Wood dorm,
which was like halfway across campus
in a weird spot where
we didn't know anybody,
and it was a suite.
And you spent a lot of time
with Jack freshman year.
You had a number of friends
that were suite mates, right?
Yeah, I had... Yeah. Yep.
And so 'cause it, now
that I think about it,
because junior year,
which we'll get to in a
second, we moved off campus,
because we met at the
beginning of sophomore year,
it turns out that a lot
happened during sophomore year,
because sophomore year was
our last year in Sime dorm,
so that was when Sime dorm, room 24,
which has since been turned
into a storage closet,
because the window opens
up underneath the stairs.
But that was the year that
we got into smoking cigars.
We would crawl out through that window.
In that little area.
I have fond memories of that window.
Tell us what you remember.
Well, I remember we would smoke cigars.
Did we get into the pipes
by that point? I don't know.
Yes. Pipes by George. Yes.
Oh, it was low.
There were some chairs.
It was chairs permanently staged
out under the stairs area,
and it was a dirt floor
and it was dark and damp.
It was.
Yeah, because it wasn't good
for our respiratory health.
The only window for our dorm room--
You had people walking, out of the Sime,
you can hear them walking out talking.
Right. Because the main entrance to Sime
was these huge cement stairs.
And then underneath that staircase was,
it was just open air, but
that's where our window was.
So our window never got sunlight,
and we would open the window,
and we would crawl out of our window
into underneath the stairs
where everybody's walking
into the first floor.
And there's bushes on both sides.
So it was like completely
walled in, it was like a cave.
You couldn't, you probably could have,
but you didn't go from
underneath the stairs outside.
No, we never did that.
It was enclosed.
I'm so sad that they made that
into a, not a room anymore
because it was the best room.
It was great to be a college
student in there because--
Students don't need sunlight.
No matter what time of day
it was, you could sleep.
It was like having room-darkening blinds,
but it was just the staircase.
And I remember, yeah,
if you didn't get us into
cigars, I don't know who did,
but what would happen was you would say,
"Hey, let's hang out,"
and we'll smoke cigars
and you would come over.
Backwoods.
We started with Backwoods.
We were not doing pipes at that time.
Well, that's 'cause we
didn't have a lot of money.
I do remember we would
save up and you were like,
"We need to go to this place
called Pipes by George."
And we would go down
on Hillsborough Street.
It's still there.
Oh, you checked last time you went?
Yeah. It's still there.
And you knew George because
you had been in there.
Yep. Was first name basis with George.
And you remember what
his catch phrase was?
No. Well, he would say, packing the pipe,
"Pack it like a baby, pack it like a mama,
"and, pack it like a daddy."
or something like that.
But when you ask them about like,
what do you think about this one?
Oh smooth. This is--
Yeah. They were all--
Smooth.
It's real smooth.
Everything. I was like,
"George, do you have a
tobacco that's not smooth?"
"No. I specialize in smooth."
So we would go in there,
and we would buy cigars,
and we'd save up money to
get like the nicer ones.
Like a $7 cigar.
And I remember--
That was a big Friday night.
We would go sit underneath
the stoop, and you're right.
There was dirt. It was a dirt floor.
It was dank and dark under there.
And one day, I mean, you
would call and be like,
"I'm coming over."
And then he came over and
Gregg was dragging a chair.
and we were like, "Where did you get this?
This looks like one of the
chairs from the student center."
Do you remember that?
Yeah, I remember now. Yeah.
I wouldn't have remembered
that, but yeah. Yeah.
I Brought a chair over.
You borrowed it, permanent.
Hold on. He was a student.
He was a student.
I mean, he's paying
tuition. It's his chair.
Just because it's not
currently in the student center
doesn't mean he can't use it.
He didn't take it off campus.
He just brought it to the
little hole under the stairs.
That was our level of subversion.
He was like, we were so by the book,
and I'm talking capital B book here,
and I mean, Gregg, you were very much,
do you remember us being like very pious?
But then, I guess to finish my point,
then you can answer the question
is whenever he would come
over and he'd stolen a chair,
and we're smoking cigars
and we're just blowing
all the smoke around the entrance to the,
I just felt like we were
being, well, we were edgy.
I think I wouldn't say that we were pious,
we were zealous.
There's a very distinct
difference between those things.
Pious is someone who is
obsessed with rule following.
Now, we were good guys and everything.
But we were zealous.
It's more about belief.
About our belief and our faith, but the--
I so rule.
I remember that time being the first time,
not that we didn't do this before,
but when you're sitting under
the stairs, smoking a cigar
is when you start just
talking about stuff,
and considering a night out,
just a three hour
conversation about something.
Yeah. Every weekend.
That was the beginning
of that being a staple,
because we weren't going out and partying.
Nope.
Do you remember us being zealous?
Was that a part of the equation
of these guys are different?
No, that wasn't part of the equation.
I do think you might have been zealous.
But never really took that into account,
to be honest with you.
Because if you came from a place
where you were doing things
that were off limits for us.
So then once you came into the fold
and Todd was trying to get
you into campus crusade.
Once you became our
friend, it was just like,
you were all in at that point.
Which came first?
Being friends with us or being Christians?
Did we rope you into like
really going all in for Jesus?
No, you guys didn't.
Well this kind of goes to
you guys' deconstruction.
Yeah.
I've thought about this a lot, actually,
because when I became a Christian,
I met you guys shortly thereafter.
And I thought of like,
what does this say about me?
Like does their deconstruction,
what effect does it have on me?
But I kind of realized that.
I deconstructed many years before.
I grew up in a Christian home,
and at some point I said,
this is not for me.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
So I kind of rethought the whole thing,
and ended up where I am.
Where I was at that point in time.
And you guys were just great friends.
I just loved being around you,
and I still wish I could relive it all.
It was a wonderful time
in my life to hang out
and nothing beats those college years.
Those are the best years that I remember.
Yeah. Because it's like you said,
the definition of entertainment
was just the three of us
hanging out for hours,
just talking, just talking.
And I think there was no, yeah,
we were just getting a kick
out of each other.
It was just being on the same wavelength,
and there just being
that, I also think, Gregg,
you brought this dynamic
into our, I have to think,
it's like, I'm projecting a little bit,
because I don't remember
thinking this at the time,
and I don't remember
us talking about Gregg,
talking about you when you weren't around.
But I have to think
looking back on it that,
as close as Rhett and I were,
there was thing to bring,
You mixed things up.
Bringing a third person into the equation,
it kind of opened things up.
There's lots of things where it's like,
if the two of us are talking,
and it's even true now,
a lot of times, if we
hang out with people,
there's this dynamic, that's like,
we've heard so much about each other.
We've lived so much of our lives together,
and know so much.
It's like you bring somebody into it,
who's newer to the equation,
it opens up the conversation.
It makes it where you can talk.
You can cover new ground,
you can have a different perspective.
And I think you were
so, your sense of humor
and just you were so
game for conversation,
and you came from a different place.
Well, Wilmington.
But then it was just like,
this guy has a different vibe.
He's cool. He's weird.
He's got interesting
perspective. He's funny.
I think it had to have breathed.
It had been a breath of
fresh air into our friendship
to open it up in that way.
I kind of see, you guys
are, been best friends
for a long time.
And I think it speaks
volumes to your friendship.
That you would allow a third
best friend into that dynamic,
and it didn't affect you guys at all.
I mean, I could hang out with Rhett
or I could hang out with Link,
or we could all hang out together,
or y'all could and hang
out with each other,
and it was like there was no question
that the friendship was true.
There was never any worrying
that Rhett had a new best friend,
or link had a new best friend.
It was truly this perfect
three way friendship.
It was a perfect three way.
Yeah. That's how we
definitely thought of it.
But yeah, I was thinking about that too.
Well, I think that we were
always, without stating it,
we were always looking for somebody
to be like the third
person in our friendship,
but that takes a special person, because--
We didn't know we were looking for it,
but I do think when we found it in Gregg,
it was just very natural.
It has it has happened a
few times in our lives,
but the reason it's a
challenge is because,
we both have to like the person,
which isn't always the case. Right?
Right.
And it's not that you like
people that I don't like,
or I like people that you don't like,
it's that we are both pretty particular
in terms of where we're
gonna invest our time
and who's gonna be our friend,
and that's kinda always been the case.
We're both very tough, and as we said,
we like spending time with
people, and then like retreating,
and analyzing the person
and the experience,
the two of us later.
And I think if we ever
talked about you, Gregg,
it was like all the stuff
that I've already said,
and it was all positive,
and there was this vibe
that, yeah, I'm actually very surprised
that there was something about
the nature of our dynamic,
that you brought something
that I wasn't threatened by.
Because I have to think that
very well could have been part
of the equation, but it never was.
Because we did hang out the,
I wanna talk about the dynamic
with how we did hang out,
how we spent our time, it was based--
You hung out with Gregg a lot more
than I did during the school week.
And we'll talk about why that was,
but one of the things
that happened early on
that sophomore year, I'll
was see if you remember this,
and I don't remember
exactly how it came up,
but we got you to cut your hair.
If you remember your-
Mop top.
Your freshman year haircut,
and then you went, basically, just buzz,
and you basically had the buzz cut
for a very long time after that.
Do you remember what--
Did I cut his hair?
Did I cut your hair?
Probably.
I'm sure we all cut each other's hair.
We had the Clippers.
Yeah.
You were cutting my hair
in college, for sure.
You don't remember us talking
you into cutting your hair?
No, I thought I always had that haircut.
No dude. When we met you--
Freshman year, man, you had
a lot of hair on top of head.
Looked like a wig.
Well, we called it the mushroom.
You had a mushroom, dude.
We gave you a makeover and then you guys,
I mean, whenever you guys
would hang out without me,
you'd be playing Twisted Metal.
Well, but let's establish why.
You studied all the time.
I studied a lot, in my freshman year.
I studied a whole lot in my freshman year.
I got all A's and I was like, okay.
Been there, done that.
This doesn't need to be
what college is about.
So starting sophomore year, I was like,
I'm gonna study enough to get outta here
with a respectable GPA but--
But you also had another
guy, who wasn't me
that gave you opportunity to do stuff.
Well, and then Gregg.
When I was not giving you any opportunity.
Gregg is famous for the line,
when I was over there at his place,
and we were getting ready
to play another round--
See if he remembers it?
of twisted metal.
'Cause that was our
game. You remember that?
Twisted metal was our game.
Now, do you remember what
you told me when I was like,
I gotta go study, man.
You know what you know,
you don't learn anything.
I live by that.
You know what you know,
you don't learn anything.
And then there was like
this corollary of like
everything I know I
learned in kindergarten.
Was that also you?
No, I don't think so.
Okay.
The catch phrase.
I mean, me and Gregg--
You know what you know
you don't learn anything.
It's interesting in the dynamic
that you're talking about
with not feeling threatened
because Gregg and I
did end up spending a lot of time together
playing video games,
eating Gumbee's eat pizza.
You've never really been into video games.
You're not really into food.
So the idea of we're gonna go
and get off extra large pizza
and sit on a bench and
eat the whole thing.
That's just not Link Neal stuff.
So it was like, yeah.
But I had somebody who was like,
yeah, I do like to eat pizza
in the middle of the night.
And I do like to not
study and play video game.
And so me and Gregg had something.
So for you, from your perspective,
Gregg filled a felt need that you had
that I couldn't fulfill
as your best friend.
I wonder if we look at it the other way.
For me, what did we do
together, Gregg, without Rhett?
I don't know.
I know that the years after college,
I hung out with you more,
a lot more than I hung out with Rhett.
It's like almost two
different stages there.
Yeah.
We had a post-college stage
where we were both newly
weds, starting our marriages,
Christie and Jim were good friends.
But you go to the same church.
We went to the same church.
Ah, yeah.
So that's why we had now first stage
of post-college adulthood,
I would go over to your house,
and you still had that
Homer Simpson grill.
It was a yellow grill that
looked like from The Simpsons.
I have one of Gregg's bristle--
Still have it.
You till have it?
Still have it. Yeah.
But to go back to sophomore year.
Yeah. So you would go over there,
you would play twisted metal,
and then let's get into
the prime time of it all,
because you took over,
Garrett was a senior,
a freshman year-ish.
He was the MC, he was leaving.
He pulled you under his wing,
and you were just waiting
for him and Todd to ask you
to step up and be the MC.
You were lobbying for that.
Yeah.
And I was in support of that,
but it was like there was
these recruiting conversations.
It was interesting. But
then you got the job.
It was no pay.
And then, because I was already upfront.
We were both in that the most
visible roles as students
to shape what the weekly
meeting looked like,
and, of course we would talk about,
you'd be working up stuff
that you were gonna do in your monologue.
I'd like to walk through
what a primetime episode
would look like, but of course, Gregg,
you were wrapped up in all
this because we were a trio.
If we were both shaping the
meeting and having ideas,
I think pretty quickly, you
got involved on stage two,
basically, as the Andy
Richter to Rhett's Conan
or Ed McMahon to his Johnny Carson.
Well, I just remember him thinking that--
Like a sidekick.
Gregg was hilarious,
that everybody thought that he was funny,
and he had really interesting
ways of saying things.
Yeah.
And so I was just like,
why don't you come up
and just give a deep thought?
So it was obviously a throwback
to the Jack Handey thing
from the SNL days, but it was just like,
Gregg, do you have a deep thought for us?
And then I honestly don't
remember how those were concocted.
I don't know.
I remember how they were concocted.
Okay.
We would sit back before the meeting,
and We would all come up
with this deep thought,
and you guys would perfectly
plan out what I was gonna say.
And I could never say it.
Never say it quite as written-
But there was a--
Which was part of the
thing that made it great.
And then a lot of times,
You and I would be working
on it because, Rhett,
you'd be working on your monologue.
Right.
So then while you're
getting prepared last minute
for that, Gregg, you and I
would be over on the side,
and I would be drilling
you in your deep thought.
I mean, you do remember
the preamble to it, right?
That was the same every time.
Yeah. Yeah.
I didn't mess that up. I don't think.
Let's hear it.
After much deep thought
and great meditation,
I've come to the realization.
That.
That...
And then you would say it.
I don't know. I don't remember one.
Yeah. I don't remember any of that.
After much deep thought
and great meditation,
I've come to the realization
that if you're gonna walk backwards,
you're only seeing where you've been,
but that's not a bad thing,
if you're about to walk off a cliff.
I don't know. I made that up,
but they would be that non sequitur--
And they were very unrelated.
They weren't themed to anything
that I was talking about,
because what I was doing every single week
is, I mean, this is one of
my favorite times in my life,
because I had this audience,
and I basically was like, I'm
writing a standup routine,
an original standup
routine every single week.
I was much more excited about
that than I was studying.
And it was just like,
okay, well, this week,
I'm gonna tell this story,
or this week, I'm gonna do this.
And I remember one week I was like,
I had gotten so much confidence.
Was way overconfident.
I was like this week, I'm not
letting myself think about
any of it until I'm up there,
and I'm doing it all off the cuff.
I don't think that one went that well.
And of course there was the video aspect,
probably was about one out of 10.
Let's paint a picture
for how this went, so--
We did that two times a semester.
The weekly meeting every Thursday night,
it would start I think when you started,
maybe it might have been
a few hundred people,
and then that was sophomore
year, junior year, senior year,
by senior year, it was
the largest campus group.
There was like over a
thousand students coming
to this thing.
They had to start moving the venue.
And it wasn't just
because of any one thing.
I mean, the fact that, yeah,
there was a lot of comedy
involved, it was very fun.
It was a fun environment to
be in, so that was a factor.
There were other factors too,
but I think it definitely
was a positive contribution
to the numbers growing every week.
It became kind of this spectacle,
if you're gonna show up to this thing.
And in my mind, I was
very much a part of it.
Obviously in your mind,
you were the center of it as the host,
and Gregg is sidekick, but
Whenever we'd get together,
sophomore year, and then junior year,
when we moved into an apartment,
the three of us together,
it was like the epicenter of planning,
working with Todd on planning an episode,
I mean, a meeting.
So the meeting would start with singing,
and I would lead the singing.
So I would be up there
and like saying stuff
in between songs and kind of scratching
that itch of like having an audience.
But it was very spiritual.
It was very spiritual. I
had to stay in my lane.
But then the next thing that would happen
is you would come out as
the MC and do a welcome,
but a lot of times we saw
that as an opportunity
to create a video,
and they had done this in years past,
create a video where it would
be this comedy lead up to you.
It would always be you're doing something,
some sort of adventure or something,
and then the way the
video would always end is
you walking up the stairs
to the front of the venue,
and then you would come
in and you'd be there.
So it would seem like a
continuation of the video live.
And in reality, I think
we probably only did that
at the beginning of each semester
Because, literally, we
had to make the videos,
and then I was going home to
my dad's office in Buoys Creek
and editing them on two VCRs.
This was still before a
non-linear editing system.
If we were in college right now,
we would've been doing
videos every single week,
but we didn't have the capacity to do it.
So at first you would just come out,
maybe without a video,
but then when we started making videos,
you and Gregg would come out as a duo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As a comedy duo.
The two of you would come out,
and so the video was a set piece
to introduce the two of you,
whenever we could make those.
And I was the director,
DP, I was the cameraman.
Right.
And you and I were very
involved in coming up
with what these videos would be,
and then it would be kind
of some sort of storyline,
sometimes Gregg would be lost
or you would be fighting. I don't know.
I had to find Gregg a couple
of times, and then I think--
In one of them, you actually carried--
I carried you in.
You carried Gregg in,
like he was passed out
or dead or something.
I never thought of this, but
why did I never find Rhett?
You were the sidekick.
You were the side kick.
I had to find you in
order to feel complete.
You would come down the aisle together
and then Rhett would be,
you would stand on the side,
Rhett would do his monologue,
I would be sitting in the
audience, laughing the loudest.
I was basically doing what Stevie does
in "Good Mythical Morning."
You would let the crowd, the
person who sits under the-
I'd break the icebreaker. I'd break--
Everybody know it's okay to laugh.
It's okay to laugh.
Applause coach.
Yeah.
I would laugh, not applaud.
So Gregg, you would be standing
up there the whole time
that Rhett was giving his monologue,
and occasionally, Rhett would turn to you,
and have an exchange if he wanted to.
But otherwise you were
just kind of standing there
awkwardly, waiting to
give your deep thought,
which was hilarious, not the deep thought.
The fact that you were
just standing up there
was just kind of funny to me.
And then you would say
something like Gregg,
and you would know it
would have a pattern,
video or not monologue.
And then you would turn to Gregg and say,
"Hey, Gregg," or you might
say, "What's up. Gregg?"
and he'd say, "Good."
And I'd say, "Gregg, you've
been thinking about anything?"
We always set it up as--
So everyone would, expect--
It was a natural conversation.
this really anti-climatic deep thought
that I was waiting for
you to totally screw up,
which was an added layer of,
but you were good at it.
Something about you delivery.
People, loved it. People
loved it every time.
And then after that, we'd
probably sing some more songs,
there might be promotions
for different events,
and then there'd be a speaker,
and then there'd be more
songs, and that would be it.
So it's like really the
beginning was about the comedy.
Well, that's the interesting thing
is that the beginning of every meeting,
in addition to the funny
monologue, I would have to say,
"Campus Crusade for Crisis
"Internominational Christian Organization
"founded in 1951 by."
And I would do the spiel,
and I would be like
we operate on a three, I would
make it different every time,
but say three pronged
philosophy of win, build, send.
Win students to Christ,
build them up in their faith,
and send them out to continue
the win, build send process.
I said, stuff like that all the time.
You became because spokesman.
And then there was this weird dynamic of,
and this really became a
thing during Christmas carols
but trying to be as funny as possible,
and then being spiritual,
because a pastor would come up and speak
and do a serious talk.
It usually started humorously,
and then ended in a serious place.
And then I gotta get up there after that.
And at this point, all
the funny games are over,
and I gotta say something
that sounds like the student
response to this thing.
It was such a weird dynamic--
That talk really had an impact on you.
But Gregg, the thing I
wanna talk to you about
is do you know that, so
obviously, after we graduated
and we were engineers for a while
then Link and I went on staff for crusade
to kind of do our comedy ministry thing.
And during the support raising process,
you would have to kind of talk about,
you gotta give your spiel
and kind of explain what you're doing.
And Link was Link--
I was gonna bring this
up because I was there
for one of these meetings.
Oh. You were?
Yes, I was there when Link was presenting
the fact that Rhett and
Link were were hosting
the weekly meeting, and I looked at Link,
and I was like mm.
Yeah. And Link's simplified story
that he would give to supporters,
he overwrote you with himself.
And you were in the room for it.
Yeah. I heard the spill.
I was there for one of the presentations.
I think you gave me some money.
Thank you.
Well, listen.
To me, I was justified in doing it
because it was just too
complicated to try to explain.
I completely understand why
you did it. You weren't--
Were you upset?
No.
Yeah. You were talking to
like a 65 year old person
in Kinston North Carolina.
Yeah. Who?
Well, apparently I was
talking to Gregg at one time.
For some reason you and
I went up to Asheville
for something and you were
scrounging for supporters,
and I was like, well, I met
some people in Asheville,
so these were my contacts.
Yes.
So you took to him to Asheville,
and then he told the
story about me and him.
That's him.
Yeah.
And it probably didn't occur
to me as I was saying it.
I don't think they supported you,
they could see through your like...
Yeah. Yeah. I'm glad.
You had the perfect
opportunity to be like,
when Gregg was up there.
You could have used Gregg's
connection to these people.
You probably come outta there--
I was using Gregg. That's
very clear at this point,
but not in the right way.
Gregg, I'm sorry for erasing
you in my revisionos history.
Before that, I think there were moments
when you moved from, by junior year,
they asked you, Rhett to be the MC
for the regional Christmas conference,
and by this point, when you did that,
I was involved less at first,
but then more and more over time,
and that's where we became
a comedy duo on stage.
Yeah.
But the way that that happened was,
first of all, Gregg, I'm
interested in your perspective
on this because at that point,
the Gregg sidekick thing
didn't, I don't remember how,
but it didn't transfer over
to the regional Christmas conference.
And I didn't replace you--
I remember this.
immediately.
Okay. So the first year I did it,
the only time that you were
on Sage was during the music.
Right.
Was during the comedy music,
not the worship music,
the original songs.
That we would write together.
And the first first song
was the Unibrown song,
which was the song that we
wrote when we wrote the song
for your rehearsal dinner, which was,
"We've seen Gregg naked,
soon you will too,"
whatever that one.
Hope you enjoy it more than we do.
So when we got up there,
it was actually you
and Tim and Gregg.
Nope. Gregg wasn't there.
It was just you and Tim?
No. And I think the reason--
I was getting married.
I was getting married right then.
You were moving on.
That's why you went out of the picture.
You didn't go to Christmas conference,
you were engaged, you were moving on.
We had written and
performed at least one song
for seniors at the NC
State weekly meeting.
So we had started writing some songs.
Yeah.
That first song that we ever performed
at a Prime Time NC State
meeting for seniors,
I don't wanna go into the details of it.
But it was me.
By senior year, we had Tim move
in with us in our apartment.
So me, you and Tim were each playing
a three-headed person who
was singing back up to you-
Yeah.
Singing, so that was the
first song we ever played.
But then the second song that I remember
was the Unibrown song,
which Tim still came up there for that.
And Christmas carols.
And then after that,
there was no more Tim playing,
singing songs with us,
and I moved more into a sidekick
and then a co-host role.
Because once I was no longer a student,
and me and you were doing
our comedy thing together,
and also talking a about going on staff
is when, right at the beginning
of the whole conference,
we would both get up there together.
So that was the third year
or something like that.
So in retrospect, from that point,
Rhett and I were a comedy duo,
we were doing this full time.
And when you worked
backwards, we had done it
in Christmas Conference
so many years that,
when you go back four or five years,
then yeah, I kind of
become you in the story
just so I can get that money.
Now just to simplify.
Well, Gregg, did you ever
find yourself thinking,
man, I mean, he's not asking me
to do the deep thoughts
at Christmas Conference,
because you never told me that.
No. Never thought that never.
Okay, good. I'm don't feel bad.
I ran out of thoughts.
You ran outta deep thoughts.
You stopped thinking deeply after college.
Yeah. I've been writing them
down every week for 22 years.
Well rewinding a little
bit to that junior year,
because again, the first time,
so that was the year we
moved off campus. Right?
And this is the first time
that the two of us ever
lived with anyone else.
So of course we had
lived together freshman
and sophomore year in our dorm,
but when we decided to move
off campus to Gorman Crossings,
apartment 3000C.
I'm sure it was a no brainer
that it was gonna be the three of us.
Yeah. Yeah. That only made sense. Right?
It was so exciting.
I remember that moment too of just like,
"Hey, we're getting an apartment."
Yeah. It had stairs in it.
We each-
No, it didn't. No.
When we did the tour, it had stairs.
I remember the tour had stairs in it.
It was a two story one,
and then we ended up
getting the one story one
is what we ended up renting.
But I was like, this is so
crazy. There's carpet on stairs.
I don't know why that
was fascinating to me.
Oh yeah. We didn't get that one.
We thought that Gorman
Crossings was so nice.
It was a three bedroom apartment.
We each had our own bedroom.
It had a sliding glass
doors off the living room
that went right into like stoop,
and I was like, this is our new stoop.
We now have sunlight.
We get to sit out here and have
our three hour conversations
and smoke pipes by George.
So yeah, playing house
with your best friends.
It was so much fun. We moved Mr. Fly,
our couch into there.
We decorated the room
with the Lionel vinyl
and the Michael Jackson, Thriller vinyl.
We found a couch out by the dumpster
that looked similar to Mr. Fly.
It was like a golden and green.
Do you remember that?
Yep. And we brought in,
all the furniture was
probably from thrift stores.
Pretty junky.
And I remember you had a
thing for a label maker.
Yeah. Yeah. I labeled things.
You would label things for comedic effect.
Yep. Yep. Still do.
Like our VCR said, "VCR" on it,
which reminds me of the big God macing
initiative that I think
I was in a relationship.
You were in a relationship.
I was dating Christie.
Do you remember? Okay.
I was on the fringe of this.
Gregg, do you remember the
God macing idea that we had?
Yeah. I think we had that
idea while we were going out
the Mission Valley, dollar 50 theater.
This is where the plan
really got hashed out.
Yeah.
But it culminated
with the Plan of The Apes movie marathon.
Yeah. So for the uninitiated.
For those of you who
weren't there that night.
God macing, it was me and Gregg's idea to,
and this just goes very much against
what we were being told by Campus Crusade.
You find a girl who's not Christian,
or maybe she's not a serious Christian,
and you date her with the intention
that she would become a Christian.
And really it was,
I think it was because
we were a little bit--
That's not good though.
We were a little bit frustrated
with the pool of women
that we had at our
disposal in Campus Crusade.
Disposal.
We wanted to expand the circle,
and the only way we could justify it is,
it was an active evangelism.
How do you remember the
"Planet of The Apes" idea?
I don't know.
Like every good idea
how, who came up with it?
I don't know.
But I know that we had multiple TVs,
and we had a VCR and we figured out a way
to hook multiple TVs to one VCR.
Yeah. That's a classic, Gregg.
There was "Planet of The Apes"
In every single room in the apartment.
You created a closed
circuit television system,
in anticipation for so many
women, who you didn't know.
We wanted to it to be us and all women.
That was the plan.
So you went around campus
and started inviting--
We would go up to-
Strange women.
We would just go up to-
Well, strangers.
Group of girls talking,
and be like, "How you guys doing?
"We're showing "Planet of
The Apes" in our apartment."
Some people come. Some girls came.
They did, they showed up.
I mean, not many.
We had more TVs than we needed.
Not more TVs than women, but--
I mean, to your credit,
there was a good number of women there.
I would say there were at
least eight women there.
And I walked in and I
didn't know any of them.
And "Planet of The Apes" was showing
on at least two televisions.
I don't know if there was a third one.
Yeah. And, Gregg, we didn't provide any,
if I recall correctly.
Was there food?
There definitely wasn't alcohol.
There was no alcohol.
I don't know if we even
had drinks and food, man.
We didn't know how to throw a party.
We were just like, they're
just gonna be interested.
Why would you need drink and food?
There's "Planet of The Apes".
Oh man. I would love
to hear one of those--
No relationships came out that.
I would love to hear one of
those girls describe that.
They're out there somewhere,
and they're just like--
I think it would kind be--
These guys invited me to this thing.
Yeah. Some strangers invited
me to their apartment
to watch "Planet of The Apes".
They really built it up as a big deal.
I'm sure they don't even remember it,
because it was not memorable.
They did not mention Jesus,
because you didn't.
You can't do that on day one.
You gotta use "Planet of The Apes"
as a segue into the gospel.
Right. Bait and switch, they call that.
So you baited them with
"Planet of The Apes",
and yes, I think they would say,
well, we showed up and they were watching
"Planet of The Apes" on the VCR.
And the couches were kind
of ratty. There was no food.
They seemed very excited
that we were there,
and then we left.
I think that's what they would say.
Man.
So maybe it's not all
you hoped it would be.
Yeah. It didn't last.
But hey, you know what?
It took a lot of initiative,
and you guys really,
again, I was in a relationship.
You guys were trying to play
catch up. You still are.
I got married first.
Gregg, you got married.
I got married first. I got married in May.
You got married in December,
and then, Rhett, you got
married the next June.
Right, all within one calendar year.
And all still married to
the same lovely women.
So, Gregg, you jotted down some stuff.
One other thing here.
Relevant to what we're talking here,
there was this girl named Lindsay.
Mm-hmm. Yep.
I was talking to Lindsay.
This is the one bone I
will ever pick with Rhett,
and I've never done it, so here I go.
Oh, I'm excited about this.
Oh, yeah. I thought you would be.
There was this girl named Lindsay.
Yep. Oh, I remember.
Lindsay was interested in me,
and I was interested in Lindsay,
until Rhett got involved.
What happened?
Well, all I know, next
thing, Lindsay likes Rhett.
But she didn't though.
You were talking to her,
right? Did you go on a date?
The date was it was about to happen.
It was imminent?
It was imminent. Yes. Yes. Imminent.
But in your mind, it was imminent.
Yes, definitely.
And hold on. Did you
tell me? Did I know this?
Did I know that you liked her?
I remember it.
I remember Gregg liked her.
I remember Rhett sort of like hinting
like, would it be okay
if I talked to Lindsay?
And I mean what do you say
to your friend when they
ask if they could talk?
You were my God macing partner.
I mean, I just thought that
it was just to pretend.
No, I honestly do not. I do not remember.
Because when I think about Lindsay,
what I remember is liking her,
and then she immediately
went on summer project.
And when she came back, she
was dating one of the guys
that she met on summer project.
And when you meet somebody
on summer project,
even though it's for another school,
you've got on summer project glasses,
and you think you're in love? I don't--
Call them goggles.
Goggles.
She probably ended up
marrying him. Who knows?
But I'm sorry, Gregg.
I didn't know that you were moving in.
Sorry for what? Give a full apology.
I'm sorry for moving in on you and a girl
that you were interested in.
Well, I'm over it. I'm over it now.
I don't think I really understood
that there was something there.
I didn't know that that was happening.
I thought you were just
like, yeah, she's hot.
And I was like, yeah, she is
hot. Maybe I could talk her.
Maybe I shouldn't have said anything then.
Well, I mean, it all worked
out for the best, obviously.
Yeah. Nobody ended up with Lindsay.
She went on a summer project.
She'd ended up with
somebody if she wanted to.
You gotta lock it down--
We wish her the best.
before they go on summer
project, but I didn't.
If you said you didn't get upset at that,
there were some signature moments
where Gregg would get upset.
You had this signature way of getting mad
that was hilarious.
And I mean, literally when
you would get really angry,
we would laugh and it would do nothing,
but make you more angry.
It just makes it matter.
I distinctively remember
this one time of you,
there was a basketball involved,
and whenever you would get upset
that you would get this look on your face,
that would be like,
like your eyes would get big,
and your lips would start moving.
But you're not saying anything.
And then we'd be like, "Gregg, you're mad.
"Tell us, what's going on."
And then, I'm sorry,
I don't remember anything you were mad at.
Apparently, Lindsay.
I mean, I never moved in on any girl
that you were clearly talking to,
because I do remember that
you were talking to Lindsay.
Yes, I remember that too.
Yeah.
But I do remember at another time,
you got mad with a basketball,
and you threw the basketball
and hit, was it threw at Tim?
It was Tim?
Okay. Hit Tim in the chest with it.
From what I remember,
he was making fun of the
skinny-ness of Gregg.
Oh.
Speaking in third person here.
A very sensitive subject for myself.
Okay. For Gregg?
Yeah.
Okay. I didn't mean to bring up--
And so you too the basketball--
another traumatic experience
on top of it, but--
But I think you also got mad when we--
We hugged it out, I think.
Hey, that's one thing.
I mean, this is why I'm surprised
that we never talked
about the Lindsay thing,
because we were actually,
yeah, so junior year, we lived together,
and then, of course,
Tim joined senior year,
but we were really good at working.
I think there was an
emotional immaturity there
that I definitely think
it came through our--
At least for two of us. Yeah.
our involvement and crew,
and just sort of like,
these things are important
and being real and being
vulnerable is important.
And so we would work through our issues,
which is why I'm surprised
that we never talked
about Lindsay until now,
but I do remember the
time that we took your,
speaking of your label maker,
you had slightly different tastes.
You had like Wilmington taste,
which was a elevated above the taste that,
the boys Creek tastes.
So you would get like Edy's ice cream,
and we would get the
plastic bucket of ice cream
from Food Lion.
And you had this easy--
Food Lion ice cream. Yeah.
And we were just sitting there one night,
you weren't there, and we were like,
man, Gregg's got that Edy's ice cream.
We need that--
And the color of the Edy's
ice cream was very white.
Very nice vanilla.
You had a taste for the better ice cream.
Oh. Yeah, I did. Yeah.
We just didn't have the fight to buy it.
Because we had communal groceries.
But then on top of communal groceries--
There were some special ones.
You would have special stuff
that you just buy and label for yourself.
You labeled the Edy's for yourself,
and because everything else was communal
with the three and then the four of us,
it was never enough
because we weren't willing
to allocate enough money.
We would split one hamburger helper meal--
Four ways.
four ways.
We did it three ways, and
then when Tim came along,
we'd just went four ways.
We didn't get more hamburger
helper, we just got less each.
So yeah, the Edy's ice cream.
So we ate probably a third
to a half of your Edy's pint,
and then we took our cheap,
yellow, vanilla ice cream,
and filled it back up and
smoothed it out on top.
And then your lips started to move,
but you weren't talking.
Do you recall this?
I do, but did I get mad about that?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
No, I think you probably
thought it was hilarious
that we tried that we tried to do it.
No, no, no. I think he got mad.
No way. No way I got mad about that.
Those are the days though, man,
I've taken all of our oldest videos
and we're getting them digitized.
And because on a, you
were an editor back then.
Once we really started moving
into video editing later,
definitely when we got into YouTube,
I really wanted to the editor
and took over for that.
But yeah, it was
interesting because your dad
had the two VCRs that you
became the default editor,
and you would always
throw Led Zeppelin on it.
You just kept going back to Led Zeppelin.
We weren't even huge Led Zeppelin fans,
but it was always perfect.
Makes a great soundtrack though.
It's great for-
And it's subversive for-
entrance videos.
It's very subversive music
for a Christian organization
For Christian a organization.
Which we kind of liked that aspect,
and Barry white as well.
Yes. It was like, we were like,
we're gonna play love
making and devil music
in all of our videos that
we're making for crew.
Yeah.
And again, We were super
zealous about our faith.
But we did not like Christian music.
Yeah, we hated it.
Because we had taste.
But for that reason, we can't
put these videos out there.
The first videos that we
made for our first audience,
which featured the two
of you, prominently,
and me just in feature roles
or just behind the camera,
have never been seen
except for in front of
those live audiences.
But now I'm gonna put them
on the mythical society,
because of the Led Zeppelin of it all,
that's the only place where we
can safely put it out there.
So yeah. It's gonna be behind a paywall,
but, hey, you get what you pay for, baby.
So we're gonna do like
a director's commentary
of this thing.
We could just get rid of the soundtrack
and voice over all the parts again.
We could do that. Yeah.
Yeah. So you guys, I'm
sure you've talked about,
have you talked about the
calculus jackass story?
Has that been talked about before?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Yes, yes.
Yes, but it's been so--
We haven't called in a while.
We gotta tell that story again.
Yeah. Rhett, I was late
in the calculus class?
Yeah. It was me-
You and Tim were in the calculus class,
and we get through the semester,
I'm a back row seater.
All the way back.
All the way back. Back corner. Close to--
And how many students? Probably 40, 50?
Guess we were 100.
100?
I don't know how the idea
got stalled up, but--
Well, I remember it because
we had that British professor.
He was very serious
He kind of had a sense of humor,
but he was a very in-control professor.
He had control of his classroom.
And so at some point I
just remember thinking,
because what the heck
what would this guy do?
I was like, Gregg, if you'll stand up,
raise your hand, and when he calls on you,
stand up and say, I'm a jackass
at any point in the semester,
I will buy you a foot long.
Was that it?
From Blimpy?
From Blimpy.
Blimpy. Yeah, Blimpy.
Which is a big sandwich.
That's a big sandwich.
So this is halfway through the
semester this idea hatched?
Yeah, it must have been.
But yeah, through the semester,
Rhett's always kind of prodding me.
"When are you gonna do it?"
We're doing the end of semester exam.
Yeah, last day, exam
prep. Last day of class.
The professor had just
gone over number nine,
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it was number nine,
and he's asking, is there any
more questions on number nine?
And I raised my hand and he's like,
"Yes, yes. You in the back."
And I stand up and there's a pause.
Everyone turns around to see.
Because you stood up. Man, that wasn't,
it wasn't a protocol to stand up.
And I say, "I'm a jackass."
Well, the TA was sitting
nearby and he started laughing.
He understood what was going on.
I think we had kind of run it by him
to see what he would think. We
didn't want Fs in the class.
Right, yeah.
I didn't wanna compromise your grade.
We, what do you mean me and you?
Me, me, me.
I didn't love the class.
And do you remember
what the professor said?
Because he was very quick.
What does that make me?
Yeah I was like, yes.
Pretty great.
And he was so quick.
And then what did you do?
And then everybody laughed.
Then I back sat back down.
And then we went to Blimpy and got a sub.
He got that sub baby.
There was another incident similar.
Rhett and I were at
Carmichael and we were just,
were you playing?
You must have been playing
basketball or something,
but there's a group of
guys, they're playing 21.
Isn't 21 where you're just shooting the,
you're playing one on
one against everybody.
Against everybody. Yeah.
And Rhett says, Hey Gregg,
I want you to get in
there and get that ball
and go in for a layup.
And I don't care if you make it.
I just want you to like fall hard.
I do not play basketball but,
I get in there in the mix, I'm in the mix.
I get the ball I go for
a layup and I throw up
as hard as I can up into
the rim and it hits the rim
and it hits me in the
face and I'm laid out
and I'm up on the ground and those guys,
I'm quite sure they've
never had a better last one.
Yeah, wherever you go, Gregg,
you enrich people's lives.
I also love that. I love that jackass,
I'm a jackass.
I love jackass humor till this day
like one of my favorite movies of the year
is jackass forever.
I love it.
You love watching other people do it.
I took shepherd of that movie
because you don't care about it.
And Gregg was just the perfect--
Up for anything.
Yeah, he was like, I'm
totally gonna do this.
And it will, it'll get this reaction now.
So I mean, yeah we did.
you were the object of a lot of humor.
You were the subject
of a lot of like ideas
that we would hatch.
It was kinda like we, produced you.
We were like comedy
producers. And so it worked,
We weren't filming it.
We didn't film it at all.
It wasn't like we were puppeting you.
It was just like we saw,
I think as producers we saw how
funny you were and we wanted
to offer that up to the
classroom or to the pickup
basketball court or
whatever the case may be.
It just seemed like we were
just packaging you as a gift
to the world and you
were always game for it
and we weren't pulling one over on you.
No, no if it was in that same scenario,
I would be the Johnny Knoxville
and you would be the Steve-O.
It was a beautiful arrangement.
And you get the reaction
that you're looking for.
It's just, we weren't shooting any of it.
We were just--
But when we did film stuff--
remembering it Gregg. I mean, it was like,
you'd have an idea.
And then it would be like,
okay, this is gonna be funny.
I don't know how Gregg's,
what Gregg's gonna do,
but I know it will be even
funnier than I thought,
like it's one thing--
Especially if I did it right.
It wouldn't be funny.
You know what I'm saying?
But it's not okay, it would
be funny if he does a lay up,
but what you don't know is
that he's gonna hit himself
in the face by accident.
I remember we were shooting
this video and I was setting up
this shot and I was like, Hey, Gregg,
you've gotta run around the corner
and then into the entrance to
our dorm and I'm filming it.
I hope I can find this footage.
I'll show it on the mythical
society if I find it.
You're running and you
have these big baggy jeans,
but you didn't have an ass
and we always saw your crack, man.
Your crack was always
showing and you're like
running around the
corner. And then as you,
I remember seeing this through the camera,
clear as day you're running,
you turn the corner.
And then as you're running
your pants, start falling--
Slowly falling down.
slowly, falling down to the thigh,
to the knee, to the ankle.
But you didn't stop.
'Cause you knew exactly
what you were doing.
You knew where you needed
to go. And it's like, okay,
he's gonna make it to his mark.
He's just not gonna have
pants on when he gets there.
And like, I don't know, you
either fell or didn't fall.
He got steps from the door and fell down.
You remember that?
Yeah, yeah, I remember I was still running
and the pants were all the way down.
But it wasn't--
We couldn't show that
one in the crusade cut.
But there was a video where
you were too completely naked.
Completely naked and you
were playing video game.
Twisted metal.
And I was like, oh, shit,
we didn't say oh, shit,
but it was like, oh no, we forgot
that it's time to be at
the primetime meeting.
That was one of the
semesters opening meetings,
was me and Gregg playing
video games naked.
Naked.
And I framed it up.
I don't know why they let us
get away with any of this.
I framed it up where you
couldn't see your junk.
And then it's like, oh no, they're naked.
They're playing a game.
And then it's like, oh no,
we gotta go. And then you
both start to stand up,
but you grab your book bags in such a way
in the perfect placement.
So that, but like, I
gotta give it, listen,
you were probably naked.
You were literally probably naked.
I gotta give it to Marty
Valentine, and Mike Affy,
and Todd Smith--
For letting that go through.
For being cool with that.
Hope they don't have any
regrets about how we ended up,
but it wasn't because of that.
They knew what was important
and they were willing to have fun.
And it was like there, it's
just a couple of dudes naked
playing video games as
a joke. It'll be funny.
So first of all, Gregg,
do you have any other memories
that you've jotted down?
I love the fact that
you actually made notes.
Like we've never seen you
actually make notes for,
you've actually done homework.
This is important. This
conversation was important.
Anything else before--
No, I just wanted to
bring up one other thing.
It was Rhett's wedding rehearsal, dinner,
barbecue pick picking.
Yeah. Yeah. We had a pick picking.
Yeah. So yeah, I was at that function
and everyone, we're
sitting in a big circle.
We sit in a big circle and
everyone's going around.
They're saying how wonderful
Rhett and Jesse are.
And the need to say something important,
but I, big mistake, big mistake.
You should never sit me down
and give me the opportunity
to say something important.
But so my observation has always been
well, what happens to
Rhett will happen to link,
or what happens to Link will,
eventually, it's gonna happen.
Like if re does it like
Link is not far behind.
But my example was the
snowboarding incident.
We go snowboard for Link.
And a couple weeks later go
with Rhett same, same thing.
We both got concussions.
Both got concussions. I didn't
get a broken pelvis though.
So were you insinuating
that I was gonna have sex
with Rhett's wife?
Yep. That was the subtext.
No.
After I got done, I sat down
and after everyone else's
nice, nice little speech.
Like everyone gave a clap, polite clap
or laugh but I got nothing.
You got--
Well, the funny thing is,
is that's a wonderful thing
about rehearsal and receptions
and stuff like that.
Or that was like the night
before engagement thing
is that it's the whole
mixed company thing.
So you've got like family.
you were bringing that dynamic
of I'm gonna do something.
I'm gonna be strange--
that we would have done just amongst us.
But my grandparents were there.
And so they're like, who is that boy?
I think, we got a lot
of love for you, man.
This has been so fun, catching up,
but I think we've alluded
this in previous podcasts,
just to kind of talk about like
where our friendship is now.
And over the years, I think there was,
when we graduated and then you and Jim
went to Argentina on stuff
of campus crusade, right?
For stint.
Yes.
For over a year, like a year and a half.
And then you came back and,
you went somewhere else on stuff?
No, I came back and we lived
in Raleigh for three years.
We reconnected then, right?
Yeah. Went back to school and
then we did a lot of stuff
with you and Christie.
Then we moved to Florida and
then we moved South Africa
and here we are now in Washington.
So, and then Florida to
South Africa and Washington.
That was all engineering.
Your engineering jobs.
Yes.
I think that with distance
and with us trying to get
our careers off the ground,
it was kind of like,
as there was a drifting apart
where we really didn't
keep in touch that often,
at least that was my recollection of it.
Well things get so busy, but
when I was in South Africa,
we started talking again.
We made a way, thanks
to the internet to talk.
Yeah, that's right.
Because you and I had gotten,
we had that like second win
when we were going to church together.
And like what I said about being adults.
And then I think we
carried on some of that.
But even that started to
kind of dissolve over time
of being able to keep in
touch for a number of years.
It was the pandemic
that, I don't remember,
it may have been harm's
idea initially for us
to start talking on a regular basis,
So like that group of guys from state and,
we were better about it
earlier in the pandemic.
And then as life has slowly
sort of gotten back to normal
and people's schedules
have gotten back to normal.
It's been more difficult.
But one of the things
that we have pulled off
is we've actually planned a get together.
I'm excited about that.
It's like the troupe-ish
of middle aged men.
That could still relive
their college years
by going whitewater rafting in Colorado.
That's what I said on the group thread.
I was like, this is like the beginning
of either a horror movie.
And I said, this is like
the beginning of a thriller
where something goes wrong.
And then I think Tim said,
or a comedy like "Hot Tub Time Machine"
it's very much like middle
aged dudes who haven't hung out
in a while, all getting
together in one house.
Whitewater rafting.
We've hung out a few times
over the years seeing you guys.
And it's always like,
conversation picks up where it left off.
But I am excited to go
on a retreat together.
That's another level.
Yeah. That is another level.
It would be great. It would be good.
Yeah, it's just crazy just to see
you got all these children running around,
you got three kids?
Yeah. I got three kids.
I got three kids. You still got two kids.
I'm not gonna catch up
with you guys on that.
But, I'm just grateful
that now we're reconnected.
We're getting together.
Of course, that's assuming
nothing bad does happen
when we're on that raft. I
might regret the whole thing.
But even if it does, if
it doesn't go too bad,
that'll just be a good story.
In video.
We'll do that.
We're all gonna have GoPros on our heads.
But I'm grateful for our friendship
and Rhett and I talk so much
about our college years,
not only on this podcast,
but just in normal life.
It's like you said earlier,
it was just such a sweet
spot of a time for us.
It was such a dynamic experience.
And it would not have been the same
if you hadn't come into our lives.
And we became a trio and
it was something that,
Rhett and I, we talk so much
about how our friendship
is one of a kind and definitely
for those college years,
for those three years,
sophomore, junior, senior,
especially sophomore, junior year,
where it was the three of us so much.
It was just such a special
time that few people have that.
So we just kind of fit
together like a glove
and I wouldn't trade it for the world.
It was just super, super sweet.
Now that you reminded me of those stories,
the jackass one, of course I remember.
And I've told, I forgot
about the basketball one.
So now just prepare yourself, Gregg,
because we gotta come up
with something for you to do
when we all get together.
So you're gonna have to say
something to the raft guide
or something, put your hand
on his knee or something.
Well, but we we'll write it,
and we will egg you how to do it
And then we're gonna film it.
And then you will make it better
than we ever thought you could.
This time, there will be video evidence.
Needs to be.
Well, I know you gotta go back to work.
Gotta supervise the digging of that hole.
So don't let us keep you from--
Yeah.
All right, we'll be in touch.
All right. This is the end?
This is the end.
This is it Gregg.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.